hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legend of korra episode 9 video
big big day today star wars trailer new
korra episode everyone's really happy
black friday craziness definitely got a
big surprise in terms of a really
significant character we weren't sure
was gonna be back and we kind of found
out like we're team Korra is going to be
going in the next couple of episodes
I've also got info on when they're gonna
be airing the final episodes it's gonna
be a two-part finale not four-part like
we believed before so I'll explain that
at the end of the video
quick reminder to new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video but careful for
spoilers in case you haven't seen the
episode starting with top five moments
number five the spirit vines capture ryu
his tour group and Jinora the thing I
noticed most about the whole tour group
scene was all the questions that that
photographer was asking it was like he
was the audience you know just
questioning the logic that Mike and
Brian have set up I love the way that
they're able to poke fun at themselves
that they have characters ask the
questions that the fandom is asking it's
also a way to catch people up and remind
everyone who didn't remember about Batu
and last season or people who skipped
season two altogether scenes like this
like this kind of comedy is what I'm
gonna miss most about Korra or one of
the things I'm gonna miss most number
four opal and beifong are going to lead
a mission to get their family back so
opals freaking out
beifong basically gives her the business
and says we got to do this ourselves
obviously they've roped Bolin now into
he definitely looks like he had that
look of determination on his face like
okay I'm gonna be serious Bolin now I
don't know that we're gonna end the
season with team Korra completely split
up but it seems like for at least the
next episode or two they're gonna go on
this side mission to xiaofu and that
might be how Toph gets roped back into
the story I was kind of disappointed we
didn't see her in this episode but
because we physically were not in the
earth Kingdom or anywhere near the swamp
I think that's why they didn't include
her I think once they traveled to xiaofu
like for this rescue mission then we'll
see Toph again like we'll be near the
swamp and we'll get another shot at
kuvira number three
Korra explains what kuvira is doing with
the spirit vines and the world leaders
start to deal with her
I like that Korra got there like just as
bolin and varrick were running in now
everyone pretty much knows what the deal
is with kuvira like she's building this
giant weapon even though they didn't
reference vaatu I thought that was
interesting they didn't get really
specific they just said big blow yuppie
weapon you know like
the most non scientific explanation for
a superweapon that you could possibly
give someone and clearly none of the
world leaders are taking cora seriously
she claims this because she got her ass
handed to her by kuvira but honestly I
think that Raikou was never really hot
on her so he probably would have done
this no matter what like even if she
hadn't gotten defeated really recently
breco isn't a bad person but he is an
antagonist the most fun part though was
just the shot of Azumi where she gave
the look I knew she was gonna have a
speaking part at some point we didn't
know what was gonna come but when I saw
her I was like well obviously it's gonna
be in this scene it's like they're just
teasing us they're like nope we're not
gonna let her speak yet I don't know
that they're gonna explain who her
mother is like who Zuko's wife is before
the end of the series they might say
that for the comics but whoever she was
I'm sure she was one of the more
practical choices and a lot of people
think that it's made but I think that
they broke up in the comics and someone
asked me a little while ago about
general Iroh like the grandson I wrote
becoming Fire Lord at some point I don't
think that she's going to be advocating
anytime soon like she doesn't look like
an elderly person she seems like she's
you know relatively like 40s 50s still
has like a long time to go before she
gives up being Fire Lord she said that
she's not taking the Fire Nation into
the war just because she's so sick of
the legacy of the hundred year war and
all the trouble it caused I don't blame
her but clearly what they're teasing is
is that kuvira is going to do something
that's going to force her into the war
it's a lot like the United States during
World War two like they didn't get
involved didn't get involved until Pearl
Harbor happen until the Japanese bombed
Pearl Harbor and then that basically
incited everyone to just push Congress
to declare war that's why I think
something crazy is gonna happen with
kuvira super weapon like she could
either attack the fire nation in some
way or do something that's so crazy that
zoomy says we have to join the war now
but it really will end up being like
everyone vs kuvira at a certain point
but I think it's gonna be on Korra to
solve everything like it'll be on her to
resolve the issue and I don't think it's
gonna end with them killing kuvira
although we did get a shot as a here and
he is awfully murdery number two Korra
reconnects with raava so jumping forward
just a little bit Korra basically needs
to get over herself she has like some
sort of mental block in place like her
body is fine her powers are intact
it's just mentally she's preventing
herself from accessing her abilities I
like this concept that her abilities are
limitless
and given the things that he's done
I think that he's right based on her
accessing her powers in the spirit world
which previously was thought to be
impossible I think that she's going to
have some sort of like super energy
bending moment that won't involve her
removing kuvera's powers but I do think
that she might use them to somehow bind
the physical and the spirit realms
together or somehow heal their
connection typically when I think about
the connection between the spirit realm
in the physical realm I think about the
Banyan Grove tree or that's like the
backbone of both realities so I think
that the resolution will involve Korra
doing something with the tree then
supposedly those vines if they're
connected in Republic City run through
the entire world
each season like around this time
there's a moment where Korra comes to
some sort of realization about her
abilities or about the world itself she
gets the knowledge she needs to defeat
the villain or solve whatever big
problem there is presumably she has the
power to deal with kuvira she just needs
to develop a plan so I think we're gonna
see what that is in the next couple of
episodes I don't think she's gonna
figure it out right away Korra isn't one
of those figured out right away kind of
people she kind of figures it out as she
goes along which is why she gets her
butt kicked so often and by number one
WTF moment Korra visits to here in
prison so the biggest moment for me
wasn't so much Korra coming to her big
realization spiritually and mentally it
was actually just going to visit to here
and his reaction to her like he is so
chill like the best villains are chill
like that all the time just so creepy I
love that they're kind of implying that
he just hovers all the time and because
he's so connected to the spirit world
he probably knew that she was coming a
long time ago although he said that it
was a little bit fuzzy in the spirit
realm like he'd only heard that the
avatar hadn't been there in a long time
I'm being really interested to see if he
plays a role in the finale Korra said
she's not gonna ever forget what he did
but she has kind of learned to deal with
it a little bit or she has a little bit
better context now there was a lot of
Korra bending in this episode like the
way that she bended the spirit portals
back in book to Mike and Bryan said that
the resolution will not involve a
bending contest that could just mean
that it's not gonna involve a fight like
a fight to the death or it's not gonna
be like anger PSA's Ozai cuz that was
really what the book 3 finale was like
but it is possible that Korra could you
know somehow bend the planet or do
something really crazy because if her
abilities are limitless then that just
implies she was going to do something
crazy epic
so I think she will have some sort of
bending moment but it won't be a fight
like maybe she'll just bend the entire
world tree like she'll just bend the
tree all over the planet at the same
time or something crazy like something
on that level let me know that what was
your favorite moment and how do you
think the Fire Nation is going to be
drawn into the conflict I feel like
that's a pretty good teaser like the
minute Izumi said I'm not gonna deal
with another pointless war I feel like
that's like saying yeah she's definitely
gonna be in this war pretty soon all
it's gonna take is like some big WTF
demonstration with a weapon or kuvira
attacking the Fire Nation in some way so
overall I gave the episode a B+ I mean
it was great to bring Zaheer back
I loved the journey that Korra is on
even though I feel like a lot of people
will yell at her for that moment that
raba had where she said I've always been
here and it's like how come it's taking
Korra this long to figure that out it's
really all about her self-doubt like she
is the most self doubting avatar that
we've seen we haven't seen that many
avatars just to give her the benefit of
the doubt though most of the time when
we see the past avatars they're like in
their adult form like they've had a long
time to figure things out and they're
very headstrong like Kyoshi who's just
like I'm gonna crush everything I'm
gonna crush my problems I think that's
what everyone wants to see Korra do but
really it's all about that Zaheer speech
there are no boundaries no limitations
except the ones you create for yourself
I feel like that's gonna be the most
important legacy of like these last
episodes and if nothing else it'll
definitely give the fanfiction just some
crazy places to go I'm happy we saw more
opal I always love opals character she's
really like a soft addition to team
avatar like you don't see her as much as
you see Asami but she's every bit as
important because she's so important to
Bolin she really is like his call to
action and I didn't mention it during my
top 5 moments but Varrick and Asami
working together that was actually one
of my predictions I mean they're
basically like the two tech iasts people
that we know about in Republic City so
of course they're gonna try and develop
a countermeasure to the super weapon
Asami was looking at that magazine with
the big engine on it so I think that
Varrick is going to engineer a larger
EMP like he did back when they were
trying to escape the earth Kingdom
it sounds more complicated than it is
but that's something that we use on like
thousands and thousands of mechs
so I think raikou is going to take on
kuvira she's gonna March her army on
Republic City at some point with the
weapon and then that will provide them
their opportunity to use that giant EMP
or whatever it is they're gonna invent
I still feel like we're gonna get some
sort of crazy death star moment where
Alderaan is destroyed Alderaan in this
case could either be xiaofu or it could
be Toph or it could even be the Banyan
Grove tree something precious is
probably going to be destroyed and
that's what's going to incite the rest
of the world to war and then korra is
gonna have to rush in and call him
everyone down before everything is
destroyed
just in general great episode i think
everyone was a little disappointed with
the clip show last week so mike and
bryan said this is like the last episode
before like it's in their words they
said poop gets real which is kind of a
funny way to talk about it but basically
the last four episodes you can consider
like almost a four part finale although
technically it's gonna be a two part
finale and just to explain the schedule
so there's gonna be one new episode
every week December 19th though there's
gonna be two episodes the last two
episode 12 and 13 I will continue to do
bonus videos so feel free to leave
recommendations and I am doing a QA for
tomorrow so please leave all your
questions in the comments what's gonna
happen with this rescue mission in
xiaofu what Cora's gonna do about kuvira
what kuvira is gonna do to the Banyan
Grove tree with that super weapon and
what president Reiko is gonna do in
terms of this you know big global
conflict in a political way just a quick
reminder new mobile links up here it's
the same as the links I had over here
but click here for that Star Wars
trailer totally watch it like 10 more
times and click here for the Q&A video I
that tomorrow thank you so much for
watching so let's all just high-five and
think about how happy we are that we got
star wars and Korra on the same Black
Friday
you